hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour
I am Perri Nemiroff and I am sitting
across from my wonderful co-host
it's Halley foul and we also have two
great guests in the room if you have not
read my review of freaks or heard of
speak about the movie COI did a special
Q&A at San Diego comic-con we're big
fans of this one and we are so happy to
have directing duo Adam B Stine and Zack
Lepofsky in the studio a lip pops lip
pops is how I would say it but I think
my notes
way more sensitive what I have written
here right now it's it's a tricky one in
fact when we we met on a reality show
twelve years ago and Garry Marshall was
one of the judges of that show and we
were contestants trying to like make it
as filmmakers and he said you you're
gonna be a big star one day but you got
to change that name in your movies just
like a crazy guy I used to think the
same thing if I ever wanted to have
anything where my name had to be said
easily memorize one of the worst last
names to have but then there's the vodka
out there so now my name is plastered
all over I think it's like MMA there's a
downside though I'm the only person with
my exact name and the exact spelling
you're way too findable you know what
else is frustrating the fact that I can
never see a peri item in a souvenir
store with my leg I'm never getting
keychain or a mug because it's never
spelled right there's two other Adam
Stein's in the film industry and they
all get congratulated when it one of
them does something
I feel like we all share it together I
for sure went to one of their I'm TVs
and was like nope oh there's unready or
not there's a writer named Ryan Murphy
and I have a specify in my review I'm
like Ryan Murphy but not that Ryan
burger get this Ryan Murphy the credit
it feels pretty taken yeah to kick off
our conversation right now I wanted to
ask you what was the gateway film that
got you guys into horror at what point
did you realize it wasn't just oh this
is fun but I got a passion for this kind
of filmmaking well from for me it was
very young my mom she was a TV producer
and a friend of hers who was a director
it was like oh my god you gotta take
Zach to this movie it's Jurassic Park
it's about dinosaurs and I was like nine
and a half or ten and had only ever seen
like kids movies and my mom had no idea
what she was walking me into so we sat
down in this huge theater and I was
terrified I was convinced I was gonna be
eaten by dinosaurs for a good hour you
know like just and literally crying and
covering my eyes I don't know why my mom
didn't take me out of the theater but I
was like terrified but then I had this
sort of transitional moment sort of
after the t-rex paddock scene where I
realized I hadn't died I had not been
eaten and then realized I had missed
everything and was totally upset now at
the fact that I had missed the whole
movie and I wasn't gonna see dinosaurs
and because I was too scared and now I
realize movies can't kill you and then
so then the velociraptors scene at the
end was sort of all I saw of that film
and that and that and then realized wow
this is so exciting and I want to
experience this again and so then it's
kind of addicted from that that's a hard
answer to top
absolutely so I don't recommend showing
it to 10 year olds though we stress in
this room also about recommending movies
too much for kids like everyone who's
into horror Saw movies way too yeah of
course you shouldn't have seen and
that's why because it's so fascinating
was my parents had as a kid of the 80s
my family had a huge bootleg movie
collection where we would go rent movies
my parents would go rent movies and then
every time we rented movie they would
immediately like copy it and put it off
the shelf you know we had the camera to
VCR oh yeah he was pre-internet pirating
we had hundreds of just VHS tapes and
they weren't like ordered or catalogued
or anything so I would just go oh The
Shining what's that you know and just
pop it in and that's the shiny yeah it
was it was it was a great kids movie in
retrospect very twisted and just
haunting and I mean I just remember
being like just gripped the entire time
that you know and that feeling of
paranoia and and you know the next shoe
to drop stuck with me sounds like you're
describing your movie now well inspired
us yeah it's one of those films that I
love I'm really passionate about this
sort of growing trend in genre right now
which is like what is the genre of the
film it's you know it's a thriller a
mystery sort of superhero worry yeah
it's a lot going on some people have
described it as the kitchen sink of
genre there you know which which we
adopt we love that I mean it's funny
because when we were writing it we
didn't really think about like Oh which
genre is this gonna fit into and that's
probably why it ended up the way it
ended up because we were really just
focused on the characters and the family
and and and telling the story through
Chloe's perspective you know this said
this seven-year-old girl at the center
of the film and so the movie kind of
evolves as her emotions evolve
yeah so at the beginning of the movie
she's
terrified and doesn't know what's going
on so it's very mysterious you know
feels like a horror film but quickly you
know she's in this house that she's
never allowed to leave but at about the
20-minute mark she's for the first time
she goes outside and it suddenly starts
feeling like a Spielberg movie with like
a lot of wonder and and then you still
have this feeling of dread so I think
it's not right something's about to
happen and then eventually she
transitions to revenge and bloodlust and
you start feeling that Karen Tina or and
then it becomes sort of an adventure
thriller and you know so it basically we
just looked at whatever she's going
through are the cinematic devices we're
gonna use because the movie the whole
movies from her perspective to the point
where we shot the movie from her height
so that all the angles of all the adults
you're looking up their noses and stuff
because she's looking up at all their
noses and it makes them really
threatening and he probably has back
problems now especially with the cameras
that we could afford we're super heavy
like the nugget of an idea that kind of
sparked the whole thing was it the big
picture like superpower type thing or
was it the character of Chloe if not
something else it was the main
inspiration was my son I was I was sort
of a new father when we started writing
I had a five year old kid and we were
always just Jack and I were just
fascinated talking to him about the
world and seeing him kind of experience
and try to figure out the world his
perspective of what was real and what
was fake was completely different than
us because to him
yeah dragons and Wolverine gods you know
that really but then a car alarm would
go off and be terrified you know so kids
are just constantly trying to figure out
what is real what's safe what's not safe
and and then they do and they kind of
join us in the world of commonly
accepted understanding most of the time
but we started thinking like okay if you
had a sci-fi world what then
and and then could put the audience in
the kid's point of view then you
wouldn't be sure what's real and what's
not just like they're not sure and as
the characters figuring it out the world
you're figuring out the world and so
that was kind of the first nugget of
like
that sounds kind of interesting I wonder
what would happen you know so that was
that was the first starting point for it
something I'm really curious about is
the approach to making a movie that
feels this big when you you guys have
mentioned a low budget and a couple of
times how do you approach that in the
scripting phase to be like we know we
don't have the means to go just make
this huge world so you have to write it
in how do you approach that no
definitely we've approached it in a few
ways one is something that most people
do when they you know start at this
special level is make it a contained
thriller so that the movies in one
location because that makes it cheaper
but we were very aware that often people
have the reaction when they start a
movie and they realize it to contain
thriller they kind of immediately go oh
it's one of these movies they never
leave the house and so you know we
wanted to make sure that we went beyond
that you know that it felt like that you
had because contains rules are good
because it keeps the tension high but we
wanted to make sure it grew and grew and
grew and as we were writing we tried to
think of all sorts of different ways to
grow the scope naturally through the
film so at the beginning she leaves the
house that's one way but then also as
the climax build throughout the end what
she's able to do and what the things are
that happened in the movie without
giving too much away add just so much
more scope even though they're contained
to one location you get the sense of
such a bigger world than what you can
see but also we just did practical
things in the script like making sure
look we can't afford to see a helicopter
but we can hear one is a big cheap
there's that there's a whole scene near
the end where she's trapped you know
under this pile of rubble and you're
hearing crazy stuff going on but you're
just watching her so yeah you're hearing
a whole crowd of people but you're just
seeing a few people through the mist
like he's died of me inside when I
remember back to film school and my
thesis fell and we tried to put a BMX
helicopter in it it's like if it was
just in the damn cabin and we just heard
it we were to save so much money that is
some ways good advice yeah but in terms
of the scripting like just take a step
back
basically this movie came about because
Hawk and I were sort of struggling
filmmakers who were getting some work
but also getting fired from projects
that weren't happening and his we
weren't big enough we were just sort of
like trying to get a movie made and and
you know basically when you're in that
position it's really hard no one wants
to let you do it so you have to kind of
think of a way to make it happen without
anyone's permission so we just sat down
and said okay if we had to make a movie
for $0 that was still in that sort of
sci-fi horror reveal that we loved how
could we do it and I was one of the
first yeah one of the big inspirations
was Mark Duplass actually gave this
really famous speech at South by
Southwest okay yeah and so we so it's
you know if anyone hasn't listened to it
or seen it it's called the Cavalry's not
coming and we both just like sort of
lived by every word of that speech and
and basically just followed his advice
we in his his first he gives many steps
and we're at like step three now but his
first step is like just survey
everything you have you've got something
like you may not have money but your
uncle owns something your dad works
somewhere you own a camera of some kind
like write down all the things you got
you know his first movie they had a
puffy chair in a van and they made a
movie about a puffy chair in a van and
that launched their careers and so
originally literally taking a page from
their book Adam and I were gonna act in
it his son was going to be the kid we're
gonna shoot it in his house and the only
other location in the movies restaurant
and his family run
a restaurant in LA and so that we wrote
that movie for us to go make it without
anybody's well assist that was the first
draft and it would have been terrible if
we acted and it's right well we could
have made it the important thing and
what he says is like make that movie for
10 grand make it 400 bucks like just
make that movie no matter what and when
you make that movie it'll lead to
opportunities for you to do it again at
a at a bigger level and what ended up
happening with great fortune for us we
were prepared to basically never give
the keys away we were gonna make this
movie if it had to be us acting in it or
not but as we wrote the script and we
created it people that we knew and
friends started being like hey I think
this is actually pretty good hey
actually I'll give you a little bit of
money and oh well now we have a little
money to get a casting director well
let's we may as well at least show it to
actors that aren't us to see what we can
get and maybe someone will like it
enough even though we're not paying them
much you know you know and the first
person to respond was Bruce Dern we had
a two-time Academy Award nominee in my
role so now I can so and I kind of you
know went from there and grew a little
bit but but we never we never gave up
that that ethos of we're just gonna do
this no one can stop us because that's
what that's what hamstrung us on our
previous projects the ones that I said
we got fired for basically it was sort
of like on those projects it was you
know meant to be ten million dollar
movie something like that and then
you've got Zach or Adam at a ten million
dollar movie uh for having never done
one and eventually they just say well
maybe we need a bigger director so
that's usually how things had work or
off often what happens with most movies
is to get this amount of money you need
this actor but to get that actor you
need this thing and by the time you get
that thing that money's gone and you can
it just never comes together so we
literally lived by that only if we can
make the movie with no matter what so if
we get a hundred grand great we're
making it for a hundred grand yeah
forget a hundred fifty great we're
making four hundred fifty and there were
people that came to us close to the near
the end when we were shooting and
they're like we'll give you three
hundred grand we're like wow that's
amazing but you need to hire the
type of person blah blah blah these
requirements and we were just like sorry
but no like we don't have time to go
through that process we can't accept
your money we're making the movie anyway
and and that contagion actually started
working in our favor some people just
started coming on board because we they
realized we were going on without them
okay well I guess I'm involved and and
so the beauty of this movie is it was
something that was started with that
mark Duplass you know message and it has
done everything that he kind of hoped
that it he said that it would is you
make your movie in your voice with
whatever you've got and luckily I didn't
be more than we had initially and you
show it to the world and and they get to
see what your voice is and then from
there you meet new people and new actors
and people that said no originally might
now say yes and you can go on to
hopefully make other projects bigger
than the last you know and so if he's
listening out there thanks mark
basically we're all here because of him
I am so happy that this all had a very
happy ending for you guys but I am so
alarmed by the fact that you were hired
to direct something and then you were
fired and then I think as you said you
were fired you said because you weren't
big enough how how can that even happen
and at what phase of the process of
filmmaking is like what's the cut
happens every day it's it's so crazy how
much work you can put into something
with never getting paid and never making
the movie and having no control over if
you are the one to do it there were
projects that we both worked on for
years where we tried to you know
basically get it made and because it was
at a higher budget level it just wasn't
yeah we each had a different experience
one mine was a passion project this
writer that I knew before he was a big
deal then he became a big deal and
suddenly suddenly his old scripts were
valuable even though they hadn't changed
and I was attached but I was on a big
deal and they didn't think with me
attached they could get meaningful
actors so they fired me to get an actor
a bigger director that they thought
could get bigger actors in an atom's
case it was it was a big producer who
was involved and I worked on the script
with the writer for years and a start
they were never gonna make started
heating
ders and you know met some really
fantastic actors who wanted to be
involved but then they just decided you
know that that movie it seems like it
would only be like you know a one two
three million dollar movie we only make
fifteen million dollar movies so we're
gonna get rid of him
hires of director can justify that you
know he'll probably for every movie that
you see that whether it's good or bad
there's probably 20 30 maybe a hundred
movies that didn't get made for every
movie that does so there's every
director can tell you all the stories
and all the wonderful films that never
got made and that's why we we were just
it happened so many times that we just
like we just got to do something where
we control it at every stage even if
that means even if it means we're you
know we're the ones making the food for
craft service you know the the attic has
old insulation well let's get in there
with our masks and gloves and clear it
out like it was that kind of project
yeah what's your best advice for
mentally rebounding when that happened
because as you guys said it happened a
lot so how do you get out of that funk
that's I mean for every artist matter
what your craft is whether it's acting
or or writing or painting or being a
director you have to be the type of
person who's willing to get up every day
and be told no and get up every day and
just be told no again and just be like
that's okay I'm gonna keep going forward
and the reason is because it's your only
choice it's just who you are there's no
the pursuit of that is the only reward
that you that gives you a sense of
purpose and kind of joy so if you're the
type of person who's told no and you
give up go find something that'll make
you happy the arts because basically for
us it's the only thing that brings us
joy so you can tell us no a thousand
times and we'll keep getting up and
accepting that punishment and I think
actually finding each other
helped us get through it in a way
because you know we'd been struggling
with that and then when we started
really like collaborating in a serious
way it it really helps not go through it
alone like to have a partner that you
can say oh man that sucked okay what do
we do next
it was so helpful and you know
emotionally and also just
strategically there's one trick we use
that we there's some inspirational
speaker I I wish I knew who it was but
we saw this video he people probably
know who he is but he basically he's a
he's like a teacher for musicians at
like Juilliard or some really big school
and he teaches all the musicians that
when they screw up when they're at an
audition and they don't do their best or
they snap a string or they someone else
does better than them when when
something goes horribly wrong
immediately without thinking throw your
arms in the air and scream how
fascinating and it basically immediately
changes your perspective from this was
terrible - how interesting look at this
terrible thing that just happened that's
so fascinating something goes wrong
every day there was crazy experiences
that we never got to have that we're
also so educational because we were also
producing it ourselves - so for instance
when we did start hearing from actors
who might want to be in the movie then
we had to negotiate with their agents
like we've never done anything like that
so then you know we'd have agents on the
phone screaming at us you know about how
little we're paying they're just coming
at it from that how fascinating
perspective so having minimal resources
and pulling off this movie that truly I
think every penny you had and then some
is represented on screen what is one
moment in particular that you can
highlight that when you're on set doing
it you're like this looks ridiculous how
is it ever gonna work and then it went
oh there's no yeah there's one that
immediately comes to mind which is near
the end of the film but it was basically
a stay of shooting you know we had a
crew that was paying we were the
smallest show in this city so if anyone
was there to make money they you know
they were they could easily mistake they
could make a lot more money doing almost
anything else in the city and and it was
a tough shoot not a lot of people so by
the end of the shoot people had you know
put a lot on the line
they were very tired we were shooting
nights and the last scene in the movie
is in this abandoned mine and our art
department had been really just like
putting everything on the line
and they were behind and the whole
climax builds to this moment where
there's an incredibly impressive giant
door opens and we got there the day of
and there was no door and they're like
don't worry don't worry don't really
we're building it and there they had
been up for like 30 hours at this point
they're like sawing pieces of plywood
there's no noises off the perfect
strangers guy who's like trying to build
things as he's sleep-deprived and so
we're filming we started the door
doesn't need to be done to like halfway
through the shoot day in the middle of
the night because we're shooting during
the night because if this mine is only
open to us at night and we're shooting
and eventually I'll walk over there and
it's still like half built and there's
like cookie tins glued to it and it just
like looks like the worst thing ever and
I just know it's not going to be done
and I just turned to one of our
producers and the grips and I just say
tear it down like just tear it down and
put a green-screen there I don't know
how but at some point we're gonna be
able to afford an amazing CG door but
right now he can't and so we can't you
cook you Tim and and so they within
seconds they just rip the whole thing
apart our entire art department quit cuz
they had just oh and we still had many
more sets that day but they hadn't built
and they put up a green screen and yeah
we shot we shot it just trusting at some
point someone will volunteer to make us
and in kress an impressive 3d door and
someone did and it's one of the coolest
looking shots of the movie and very
iconic parts of the movie and and our
producer one of my oldest friends it was
a producer he had just come from a
wedding that day and it was the middle
of the night he was in an incredibly
expensive suit and was shooting in this
mine and I said our art department just
quit and there's a whole nother set that
hasn't been built but they left all the
pieces over here
can you go build it so that in an hour
we have something to shoot and he in the
mine picked up all this stuff and he was
like built this whole set his whole suit
his shoes everything was completely
ruined by mine water and but it was
there and that was kind of the love
and hard work that the movie took the
door does look good so you have an art
department that quits you have someone
who wrecks a suit to build a set on his
own what happens when you show them the
finished product for the first time have
you ever touched base again absolutely
and I think shocked and surprised no we
don't hold a grudge we know that it was
a super hard shoot like we asked we
grateful for everything that anyone did
along the way and you know we actually
had another producer who who basically
quit in right at the end of the shoot
because he was just so overwhelmed and
intimidated by the financial situation
[Music]
and he basically just disappeared
because he couldn't deal with that
stress and we weren't we don't hold a
grudge or it's just sort of like yeah
how fascinating so we've we've all those
people have now seen the movie you know
we're at Vancouver Film Festival which
is where we shot the movie and all those
people came and they were just like whoa
it really came together Wow and it's
just so awesome to share that that
feeling because they they're the ones
who know most what it was like to make
the movie so it's really cool to be able
to share that what yeah there was many
one of the key moments I remember as
Bruce Dern was on set and we wanted to
like encourage him to show him because
clearly this was like a lower budget
than he's used to and most of his great
work it's not a Tarantino movie and you
know most of our lights and everything
we're basically the few lights we could
afford were outside the window is
pointing into the rooms just kind of
giving a general natural light and on
the kind of weekend we showed him like a
bunch of still frames cuz we thought
they looked really cool to like
encourage him to see that this is really
coming together looking like a real
movie and he's looking at the steel
frames he's like wow this is incredible
and all this without a gaffer or a
lighting team
even see the light she just assumed we
had no lights whatsoever we're like no
we have lights there just outside the
windows but a lot of the scenes were
just lit lit by flashlights talked about
how like finding each other was really
important how do you practically
collaborate when it comes to writing
when it comes to on set what what is
your process and in practice yeah that's
a really good question you know with
writing we basically outline for a
really long time and we do that by just
sitting with each other and telling the
story to each other back and forth it's
funny if you ever see us in a coffee
shop because we're often jumping up from
the table and acting out seems to
convince the other person you know and
well it was actually funny we went to
the coffee shop that we wrote this movie
in I'm a few months in scones in
Larchmont and we wait and we walked over
there and still a lot of the same people
that were there when we were writing
this movie were there and we felt like
kind of like Moses or something like it
can be done the screenplays will be made
but they're still their work so we
basically like just kind of spit ball
back and forth on each scene and we
start jotting down the bullet points and
then often we go back through it and go
oh and that doesn't work actually and we
do it all over again
there's definitely moments where one of
us feel strongly about something and the
other feels very strongly about the
opposite and it's you know that's
process we've come to learn ends up
creating much better work than either of
us could have done individually because
if Adam sees it really strongly one way
and I see it really strongly some other
way usually that means there's something
actually broken about the scene
inherently or we kind of ask well why
why do you think that that's important
and why do I think this is important
what's a third idea that could achieve
both and usually that's hard but when we
find it it's always better than either
idea individually and it takes work and
it takes being putting your ego aside
but we've just found that the work ends
up being a lot better and we like to
think of it as there's twice as much
brain power rather than
having half each and then on set there's
lots of different things we do we just
try and make sure that one of us is at
each scene we kind of alternate who's
the voice to the crews and the actors so
there's sort of one voice rather than
two different voices and we've learned
all sorts of tiny techniques just
through doing it things like when I
arrive on site if I've been away before
saying anything I check without him
because often I would have come to say
that isn't supposed to be over there
suppose we go over here and there we go
the other director just said put it here
and like because of something that's
happened when I wasn't there and we also
it's kind of like a superpower yes when
one of you is right with the actors you
you can really talk to them in a more
intimate way and really kind of get
deeper with them but you need to also
have the global view that you get when
you watch a monitor way back you know
ten feet away so we get to have both and
it's really cool and then usually the
person who's right there front and
center is the one talking to everyone
but the other one will come from the
monitor and sort of scurry forward and
whisper in their ear like it was out of
focus
yeah they remember at the end of movies
an incredibly emotional scene with the
lead actress Lexi and she's crying and
it's incredibly emotional and we shot
that for almost like a like a half an
hour running taken Adam was basically
hiding under the rubble with her just
sort of working with her and but he had
no idea what we were shooting basically
he was just I couldn't see the camera
and he I just remember him crawling out
from this rubble covered in dirt you
know basically with tears in his eyes
and just kind of being like did we get
it no clue but she wouldn't have gotten
there without him and I was able to
watch the monitors and give nose to the
camera people while it was happening so
that we captured that moment so we find
that that it ends up being hugely
beneficial but it does take a lot of
work to make sure it's sufficient she is
so good in the late she's I think she's
too good he's like where do you find
someone like her is that through any
kind because I know it's it's a lot
harder probably when you have you've got
Bruce Dern coming out to you to sign
onto your project but then where do you
find this kind of you know we definitely
like when we were working on the script
there were a couple times where we
looked at each other and thought
oh my god we're really stupid we're
writing this whole movie that needs a
seven-year-old superstar like how are we
ever gonna find this person and we like
watched a lot of movies like room and
beats with a southern wild' and stuff
but like when you watch it we're like oh
the girl and beasts on a while is so
good we had to watch that and watch that
movie she like basically doesn't speak
in that movie it's also she's incredibly
she's incredibly performance but it's
all done through voiceover and she has
like so few lines and we were like oh
man we've given this little girl like
hundreds and hundreds of lines they did
that for a reason yeah Jacob Tremblay in
room tho might look quit engine a is
amazing also we were just trying to
reach for something like that and it's
very very hard to find you know those
those there's a reason those kids get so
much recognition cuz it's very rare you
know room beasts florida project like
finding a kid like that is incredibly
needle in a haystack stuff and we knew
we wanted to get to a very real place
with her so we approached the audition
process in a in a different way usually
kids come into auditions and they're
very like rehearsed because their
parents have drilled them on the lines
they want to make sure they get every
word correctly but they've forgotten all
about the meaning behind it and they
won't change like if the lines dad I
hate you
you'll be like okay good now say it
angrier dad I hate you okay no quieter
dad I hate you and it's just like it's
just the same no matter what you do and
so we took a different approach and we
have them come in to the audition room
and we were just there with our shoes
off on the floor like with coloring
books and we just said hey you know just
sit down color with us for a little bit
and you know let's talk about life you
know life's crazy huh when you like get
mad at your parents you ever get mad at
your parents and and we just kind of try
to get to know them a little bit and
then eventually we'd say like you know
what that time you're your parents
wouldn't let you go to sleep over like
let's do that scene let's just improv
that scene we had a friend who was there
to read with them and would just improv
these scenes from their own lives
and to get at the real emotion we would
see like who which kids could kind of
access the real emotions because one of
the other things about being a dad is
that I I realized something I wasn't
aware of before I was a dad how fierce
kids can be compassionate house
what big emotions they have you know
they go huge on the anger and huge on
the sadness and and and huge on the
loved like you later
and you don't see that very much on
screen you know most kids are very sort
of flat and we wanted to go to those big
places um but we needed actors who
weren't afraid to go there and when we
were with Lexi you know from the very
beginning she was reading with her
friend or improvising with our friend
[Music]
and her eyes were tearing and her
nostrils were and then you know we we
kind of feed in the lines of like try to
make it about ice-cream now instead of
sleep over and she would just kind of
seamlessly bringing the real lines from
the scene but with that same emotion and
and then when we were kind of like
almost scared by her fierceness it was
like whoa this is powerful and we said
okay okay that's great okay stop there
though that was wonderful you know cut
and she immediately switched back to
like happy seven-year-old girl and she's
like oh my god you guys are so fun that
was and that was really important too
because we wanted it we she had the
maturity to know that this is pretend
because there were a couple other kids
that we were considering at the time who
who could get to that fierce place but
then you could tell were sort of rattled
afterward by that emotional experience
and Lexi really just she saw it as an
exciting dive into her craft like she
saw she was excited by the fact that she
was able to get there
rather than traumatized so that you know
we had to do this day after day after
day so we needed someone that maturity
and when she found her was there any
tailoring that role to her specifically
mostly in sort of the details of the
world so like in
this in the movie they've been in this
house for seven years so the house
itself is a huge character and we wanted
her to kind of put her imprint so like
most of the drawings in the house are
from her and we let her sort of arrange
her room and like that kind of stuff but
so she was also the art department labor
yeah also when we were shooting I mean
we did a huge amount of improv that kind
of thing we talked about with the
audition
we continued while we were shooting
because this is the first thing we had
written and we were used to like being
Loretta first thing we've written that
got made yeah the first thing we
directed that we had also written in the
past when you direct someone else's
stuff you kind of have to be aware of
the writers desires and and your boss's
desires you're directing a movie for a
studio or a network you're sort of there
the client and you're delivering their
movie it was in this case we could
change the script or change the idea
whenever we needed to so when we would
do a scene we would know okay this is
the essential element of the scene but
the actual wording doesn't matter as
much so we would kind of do the same
thing we did in the auditions where we
get to the emotional core of what's
going on in the scene you know you want
to leave the house to get ice cream or
you want your dad to go away you don't
want him to color with you and and then
improvise around that and all the actors
were game with that and I mean Bruce is
famous for improvising everything and
Lindsay was always talking about how she
was so surprised she's in a scene with
this guy and he's not saying anything
that's in the script she's like okay I
guess I'm not waiting for my line I'm
just gonna say something and then but
that it had such an electric quality to
it when actors do that because they
don't know what their scene partners
about to say so it really kind of
they're lightning in a bottle moments
that we captured that weren't scripted
and then that became an enormous editing
challenge for our amazing editor who had
incredible amount of material to work
with
none of which matched any
and and putting that together was was
was the next part of the fun shall we
move are we I had I was gonna give you
an opportunity before I continue to
babble on I just wanted to ask because
you guys have brought up time and time
again you know studios or bosses and
things like that now that you've gotten
this movie made the way you want to get
it made
what if let's say a big studio came
knocking on your door and asked you to
do one of those huge big-budget films
would you even entertain the idea we
would never take money never we only
ever want to starve know that mean the
main thing for us is being able to we
made this movie to show people what our
voices so hopefully there's projects out
there that then are still things we'd
feel passionate about and now and it's
already started to happen people see us
now as authors rather than just as
directors so they bring us in much
earlier on potential projects to say
what would you do with this what would
be your take and they're much more
accepting of our opinion even though
it's the same opinion we would have had
before because we've sort of proven that
our opinion has a result that that has
sort of some integrity to it that people
seem to be liking so the main thing for
us is finding projects if if it did come
along something bigger if we could still
speak to our voice something that we
really wanted to do and it was with
people that seemed to want to do what we
wanted to do like I've I had made a few
horror films in the past where they
didn't want to do what I wanted to do
and in the end it didn't lead to a great
movie and so being able to find those
people that really want to make good
stuff and collaborate with you and it's
just like anything else and hopefully
with freaks you know we have a little
bit more credibility there did you
notice the game kind of changed for you
guys right after the TIFF premiere it
wasn't really immediate it was it was
more pounding the pavement actually like
because getting out of the you know
people like yourself saw it and we were
very like blown away and grateful
because when we were writing it we were
like we just gotta get this thing made
we never even pictured people seeing it
it's this really weird thing where
you're like it's a miracle if this ever
actually gets finished and most indie
movies and get if they get finished
never get seen yeah so when people
started to see it that would like that
blows away but then it was more pounding
the pavement because the industry still
wasn't aware and like you know we we
still weren't there's only people were
calling us I got the Barton Fink money
for you it was just like we had to still
go out there and be like hey watch our
movie you know and listen to this pitch
for this next thing we want to do and
Perry from Collider really likes it you
should watch it so it's it's it's always
a hustle you know but it's it's always
fun to yeah well before we run out of
time with you I kind of want to take the
the spoiler muffler off let's do it so
we wanted to talk about spoilers we're
gonna put it like a big warning so that
it's a great movie to watch it's a great
watch without knowing anything but when
you've seen it it's a great movie to
watch again because all these
everything's coming together and you're
like oh my god I can confirm that now
that I've seen it twice but I just
wanted to ask you just for fun because I
love when a movie it challenges you to
like put yourself in a character shoes
and figure out where you belong in that
world because especially now with all
the superhero movies we get you look at
someone that has superpowers like
they're the greatest luckiest person in
the world and then this situation comes
with a lot of complications so did
writing this story make you rethink
whether or not you would want a power
and if you could have one what would it
be and why well since I was very young
one of my favorite movies as a kid was
The Rocketeer and basically every day
since I've always wanted to be able to
fly every time I'm walking down the
sidewalk I think about how much better
it would be to just take a few steps and
leap into the air and fly through the
air so I would always want to be able to
fly I've thought about it every day and
everything you work on pure eyes would
bleed and someone would find you yeah
even even in that case
[Laughter]
stopping time seems pretty cool to me
there's a lot I want to do in the world
and it's just there's not enough time
[Music]
but what you were saying before was
something else that I really appreciate
with you guys is that like so much now
you know people want to know everything
about a movie before they go see it but
some of my favorite movie going
experiences as like a movie lover have
been when I'm sitting in the audience
going what the hell is going on here
wait what what's coming next I don't
know because as you know a sci-fi and
horror fan like so much of what we see
is so predictable you know in the first
five ten minutes you kind of know what's
gonna happen at the end you're just kind
of ah alright that was a cool scene one
of the big things we talked about when
we were making the movie was Adams
experience seeing The Truman Show cuz
when he saw it as a teenager in the
theater he showed up five minutes late
and in the first five minutes of the
movie they explaining every act they say
okay he's in a bubble he's in Burbank
they're shooting a TV I walked in and
and it started in his bathroom with
weird stuff you know all these people
staring at him and he was so paranoid
all these people but these people are
looking at it like why is a light
falling out of the sky and I was in his
shoes and so paranoid and it was like
the craziest most surreal horror movie
and that feeling that perspective of
being in the characters shoes and also
not being able to predict where this was
going was something we really tried to
do with this movie okay
this is it this is your official freaks
spoiler warning we are gonna jump into a
heavy spoiler conversation right now
so go leave watch the movie and after
you have then you can come back and
listen to the rest of the show yeah
Haley I leave it to you okay
I can't wait to see what this is this
boy yeah we barely rarely get to talk
about
I was actually really curious about when
it comes to world building when you're
dealing with something like superpowers
or paranormal in that realm how do you
make the rules of your world clear and
what did were there things you were like
I did not want this to be a part of our
mythology yeah I think a few of we
started from a very simple concept but
it was kind of one of the big
inspirations was his podcast This
American Life podcast actually that we
listen to it's quite famous and they
talked about basically if people had
superpowers what would they do and they
asked people if you could fly what would
you do and if you could turn invisible
what would you do and most people said
if I could fly I'd go to Paris and if I
could turn invisible I'd I'd spy on my
ex-wife and like ask all these people at
the end of the podcast he goes you know
what nobody said fight crime or like
help people and so we kind of realized
that's totally true if if people had
powers they would just use them for
themselves and so one of our first rules
was they never helped people they never
try and save the world
they never get into a group and have
nicknames and wear fancy clothes
basically people only just have these
powers and they use them for themselves
and then sort of our world building came
from there so basically if people did
that government and people without
powers would start to not like these
people turning invisible and stealing
stuff or whatever and would make it
illegal and if they made it illegal
those people would have to do it more
and go underground and if they went
underground people would trust them less
and they're basically a cycle of
violence and so we just quickly just
started thinking about what the real
world would do and then we and then from
there looked at all different times of
history where the government or people
have persecuted or separated or shot
into people from being different and
then just basically asked ourselves how
could we do that in this world and so a
lot of the details in the movie like her
being put into a family across the
street to pretend like she's not not
special is you know related to like kids
in World War two being Jewish kids being
put into other families when I grew up
going to Jewish
and they would always every day we would
have basically holocaust stories and so
you know stories of parents trying to
protect their kids that that kind of
Kindertransport thing that influenced
that element but we were also writing it
during Trump's camp campaign and just
the xenophobic rhetoric and stuff all
found its way into the the stew of the
world but I think your question was what
didn't we want to include that answer
particularly about them not fighting
crime and stuff is really interesting
yeah but are there other things that you
were like this is not our version of
powers yeah well absolutely one of the
other important things was not making
anyone good or evil yeah like no one in
life is all good or all evil and so much
of the superhero mythology is about that
and we just wanted all the characters to
be human and messy and you know have big
plans and then fail yeah which is stuff
you don't really see like usually in the
superhero genre it's like they have a
plan maybe they fail a little but then
they succeed and they're always trying
to save the world you know wanted to
them just be saving themselves another
rule that we put in place was when you
watch Marvel movies and stuff they
basically seem to have unlimited amounts
of use of their power which we were like
that you know if we had to jog across
the street we'd be tired imagine if you
had to like you we wanted the idea that
these powers take a physical toll like
running a marathon and so that we kind
of came up with these four stages is if
you had you know pew pew pew powers that
would that would probably so we we had
actually what would actually be used to
be a huge bigger part of the movie about
yes a few times you see him drinking
Gatorade and that was sort of related to
this idea that using powers is like
running a marathon and they have to like
replenish their electrolytes and stuff
and basically the four stems gets so
exhausted he passes out the four steps
where first you get tired the second
step was your ice basically you start
hemorrhaging your eyes start bleeding
the third step is you start bleeding out
of the mouth and then the last step as
you pass out and so a few times in the
movie you see them can
can you through those steps and then the
last kind of thing about the powers that
was a rule for us was that each of the
powers are based on what their deepest
desire is so basically each of the
characters powers is related to their
character and what they want so Chloe is
a kid who just wants control and wants
to get outside and so her two powers are
mind control and the ability to kind of
bait we called it mental Skype basically
bring people mentally into her space
because she can't leave the space and
then mom wants to escape so she can fly
dad wants to protect his daughter and so
he puts her in a literal bubble he wants
to basically stop the world from finding
her and Bruce turns just a trickster
visible and manipulate people and and
that type of stuff so and you know our
thought there was just that way it was
sort of really grounded and came from
the characters rather than you know just
oh that person can yeah arrows really
the other thing we started to like as
writers started to go back into the
tropes of like okay well maybe they have
some high tech like sci-fi way of
detecting these people's DNA and stuff
like that now we're like no they don't
have any of that this is art this should
be our world you know the only thing
they've got are these UV flashlights
whether trying to see blood traces like
that's what we have so we didn't want
like sci-fi weaponry or like you know
special antidotes to the powers we often
when we were writing to it you'd start
to want to do the easy thing which is
like okay they hack into the system and
they find out this information and then
we go no no no no no if we had to break
into a jail like how would we do it and
we'd be like like we have no ability to
do it so what would we try and we just
like so we kept asking ourselves with
the whole writing process like what
would we do with normal people really do
I know if they had to do this stuff I
have so many questions but now I can
picture myself doing right now is
running a marathon with my eyes leaning
did you ever imagine what life would be
like for individuals with powers in
other countries especially considering
you wrote this during a an interesting
of political climate
I mean one of the unfortunate things is
that like it's not persecution of the
other isn't limited to America it's like
happened everywhere and always
throughout history so to the point where
people asked us the film came out at the
Toronto Film Festival which was a few
years after Trump's election and at the
time it was just happening that kids
were being separated from their families
and putting in you know basically in
camps and everyone was like which
happens in our movie basically and they
were like how did you know like this is
so relevant and we're like well
unfortunately basically when we started
writing this movie that was science
fiction but we went through history and
just looked at what happens and that's a
perceives itself people just when they
find the other they put them in camps
and separate them you know and and
that's what was happening again and so
it wasn't that we were verifying thought
Trump you know when we were writing we
we thought Trump would lose and he would
just be this like ridiculous footnote to
history
we actually had conversations about
should we go down this path because it's
prom this won't be relevant in two years
when the movie comes out we're worried
we're like how far should we go there's
no one's gonna care about you know
xenophobes you know phobia and stuff
like and it only got worse which we
didn't because nobody likes to say
goodbye on a note I'm also very curious
about the extent to which since this is
so much built around a sense of mystery
how many of those questions you wanted
to directly answer how many sort of
things you wanted to leave open to
interpretation like Dallas Times like
that all these references to her
mother's history things like yeah how
deep you're getting okay well one of the
crazy things is that's really hard to do
when you're writing a mystery is to
write a mystery because you know all the
answers so you're trying to write
something guessing at which point people
will make the connection and you can't
over explain it because then they're
ahead or they they feel like you're
talking down to them but you can't under
x-plane it because then they feel like
okay get on with it I want to know the
answer and so we did this really massive
our script we yeah we thought oh my gosh
we've planned out the perfect reveals
and like it's so mysterious and we did a
staged reading of
and nobody got it they were like they
got to the end they're like what
happened are they ghosts is this all
agree dad's head right and so that
really set us on this path kind of being
inspired by Pixar and the other
Animation Studios that do a lot of
iteration we're like okay we've got no
money but but we're willing to put in
the sweat of like constantly rewriting
it so we would kind of we did five or
six staged readings while we were
writing with newbie you know fresh fresh
ears and we would get actor friends
together and read the script for just a
small group of like ten people to see
what they were getting when you know
sometimes we would stop every 10 pages
and be like what do you think's going on
like who are you bored now we do the
same thing in the editing like we edited
for three or four months and showed the
movie every single weekend to a group of
five people and they would say like one
of the hardest ones was dad's power and
the original draft of the script it was
all done with sound no bubble and you
just we just thought people would get it
like that they would hear the birds the
birds would stop chirping and stuff and
everyone was like what is dad's power
like I don't understand when he froze
her in the middle of street and they
were like what is going on what like no
one understood it whatsoever Dallas was
actually something that was added in the
editing oh really
people would say like they would say uh
why don't they why I get that they don't
like freaks but why do they really not
like freaks I don't get it like and we
realized we needed some sort of 911 type
just a tinkle of it that you just if you
saw that there was an attack anything
they did was justified but without that
or they would think anything is
justified so yeah so with Dallas we we
wanted to we wanted to come up with a
medium sized you know big city but where
nothing has happened in our world so
that people would really be like whoa
and they're sort of in our minds a
debate to be had where the government
says freak kid was in Dallas and Dallas
got destroyed and that's why we need to
kill all these kids but it could have
been that freak kids were there
and they dropped a bomb on Dallas and
are blaming the free kids but they're
they're the ones who I'd do anything is
we it's sort of that you know in this
world it's probably conspiracy theory
for Dallas truthers trying to get to the
bottom of what happened in Dallas the
funny thing is we showed the movie in
Dallas at the Dallas International Film
Festival and everyone was we were kind
of nervous we were like what's gonna
happen are they gonna like hate their
language their reaction was something we
did not anticipate which was that was so
cool you change it for every city like
[Laughter]
but yeah so throughout the whole movie
there was a lot of figuring out and it's
really interesting one things we learned
which I didn't know before doing the
movie was there's almost a bell curve
like some people would get stuff way
earlier compared to others
some people would get it way later and
the most people would kind of get get
certain things we would stop the movie
and say at what point did you realize
she had powers and no one would say the
same thing it's not like there was like
one thing where I see dead people and
everyone gets it like it's this moving
bell curve and so it's interesting when
you're trying to make something to kind
of keep everyone interested the ones
that are way ahead of it and the ones
that are kind of lagging behind yeah and
on second viewing we we hope it's really
fun for people and second viewing
because we had a lot of Easter egg type
seeds that are planted in there where
for instance the sound when the time
bubble is up we took crickets and birds
sort of the typical and ambient sounds
and slowed them down 10,000 percent so
it's got this weird feeling almost like
you're in a submarine and there's a
whale song going on out there is froze
but it's actually crickets and and then
like when his power stops and time comes
back to normal it immediately goes back
to the normal ambience so it's just one
kind of example of like something you
might get on second view yeah I mean to
go even deeper something that no one
will notice unless we explain it to you
is we did a lot of thing about what it
would be like to live inside of a time
bubble and one of the things we realized
is water and electricity wouldn't
function because water pressure and
electron flow wouldn't correctly go
through the bubble and so they drink out
of bottled water and have batteries
whenever they're in the bubble and
whenever you
to sleep the lights turn on and the top
starts dripping and stuff like that so
we went pretty deep into what it would
be before we have to wrap up I have one
more story question for you in this
world that you created here are human
superpowers something that turned on for
a specific reason or is it something
that evolves because it is really - they
get more powerful with you we see if it
gets powered by every more powerful with
every generation then you can kind of go
backwards where you know Grandpa's
generation has powers that are visible
but his grandpa may have had very minor
powers and his grandpa may have had
almost the slightest doodle maybe he
just had a great intuition or something
but over time as these different people
with abilities met up and as segregation
and and kind of persecution force them
together sort of it made a pure line of
this mutation or whatever it is that
gives them abilities that gets more and
more powerful with every generation but
maybe Merritt Merlin back in the day was
just sort of but it's also minor freak
it's also you know an unintended result
of the ghettoization you know as though
as they get kind of forced together they
have kids together who are then more
powerful that's great I really make
another movie to talk about that for us
to make another movie people have to
show up and watch this
so you guys were early supporters of the
film and we're forever grateful and now
it's just you know we just hope people
come and see it
Friday the 13th yes guys Friday the 13th
September 13th please go see this movie
also for both of you is there anywhere
everyone can find you on social media
Instagram Twitter whatever you got yeah
I'm on instagram at Zach dot Lepofsky
and I'm on Instagram and Twitter at Adam
Stein all right and Hayley before we
close it out you take it away
I really want to ask more questions but
we can haley Felton on instagram at
haystack McGrew be and i'm at p number
off on twitter and instagram thank you
guys so much for watching another
reminder check out freaks September 13th
don't miss it guys you have officially
survived the witching hour